there's a brand new tax plan coming out
of california and oh man does this show
that california literally is trying to
kick citizens out of their country wait
it's not a country it's a state but
remember tim draper wanted to make it a
country he wanted to actually break it
up in a bunch of different parts
california is considering doubling their
taxes what it's already one of the
highest state taxes in the country but
california lawmakers have introduced a
plan to almost double state tax revenue
at an additional cost of twelve thousand
two hundred and fifty dollars per
household
the new tax would be
18.05 percent all-in top marginal rate
on income
what that is literally
almost
half of the federal rate income tax a
2.3 grt would be three x donations
current highest these people have lost
their minds if you think that people are
going to stay in your state and pay
18
at the highest tax rates for state
income tax that is insane
the average cost per household would be
an additional twelve thousand two
hundred and fifty dollars
if somebody makes
sixty thousand dollars a year
they essentially want them to pay an
additional on top of the taxes they
already pay
an additional 20 of the income they pull
in every year
to double the state
tax revenue
i don't think that this is going to get
passed but if it did this would be
absolute suicide for a state that
already has seen people leaving at an
alarming rate to the point where they've
literally lost legislative seats
because ultimately people want to live
in a place where not only are they
willing to pay taxes but they want to
get good value for the taxes that
they're paying
and in cities like la and san francisco
homelessness crime murders etc is all up
it's a huge problem
and then on top of it you basically
aren't improving the service that you
give people
but you're asking them now to
potentially pay
18
we're talking about at the highest tax
rates people paying 55 to 60
of all their income
to the government
we're heading the wrong direction folks
i don't think that that's gonna fly but
this is just
absolutely the arrogance
to even propose something like this is
pretty incredible what do you think john
i think they're trying to drive away
their citizens at this point 16 other
states have implemented or enacted
um
corporate or individual like basically
uh what they call it tax cuts right
they're trying to drive citizens to
their state and um because they realize
that the the benefit of having more
citizens can help but this is this is
just absurd the fact that anyone would
pay 60 of what they make to the
government is is just it's just not
right
i mean if you go to work every day
and you're paying
55
of your income to the government
or more
you got to start asking yourself what am
i doing here
this is i think the number of citizens
that were
leaving
or uh joining
various states
number one net gain
florida
200 000
texas 170 000 or so net gain guess where
those people came from well new york and
california lost everybody like it's not
that uh like people like to joke about
this but like it's literally in the data
tons of people left new york and
california at the bottom that in an
outlier standpoint right it's not like
oh they just were a little more than
everybody else no tons of people
compared to all the other states left
california and new york
and they moved to texas and florida
again outliers in terms of net growth
yeah people chose to vote with their
feet and they left and they went to
states with low to no
state income tax and generally treating
the
uh citizens with
hands off
you can make your own decisions we don't
need to intrude in your life and we're
going to give you uh one a
business-friendly environment where
we're actually cheering for your success
and two is we believe that you should
make your own decisions around various
things in your life and that is
everything from economy to public health
to other things and so again it's just
right there in the data like people left
new york and california they don't give
a [ __ ] anymore they're like i'm leaving
your state because you are literally
ruining it and i'm gonna go to florida
and texas but now california lawmakers
are doubling down it's it's not bad
enough like if you saw that data the
first thing you would do if you're
running a business you say time out time
out what's wrong
we're losing people it's a net loss why
are people leaving what's wrong how do
we fix it instead they're like you know
what we're gonna do we're gonna replace
those people by charging you more we're
gonna double our revenue by charging you
18 state all-in tax income
they do that that chart might be i mean
double or triple what it was new york
makes a lot of sense during what
happened in the last 18 months to lose
citizens about one-third of them
probably or just under one-third of them
live in new york city which was a highly
densely populated area covid everything
that went along with that but california
is there there are suburbs in california
that people could have retreated to and
instead they're just like i gotta get
out of here yeah that speaks to that
speaks to the higher level of what's
happening at the state level rather than
just hey i don't feel safe in this city
yeah
if it was a crime only thing they would
just move within the state right say hey
i don't live in the city anymore i'm
gonna go to the suburbs i think it's a
fantastic point but they chose to move
across the country folks
we're not talking about also like there
are there are some people i know that
went from la to las vegas or they went
from california to utah right where it's
like i'll just go right across i can
still get back here
people chose to move across the country
from california new york to florida and
texas
people voting man so it happens